here are the questions people are asking
from the internet if Vermont is able to
secure a single-payer health care system
hi yes Bernie you making headlines do
you think it will eventually spread to
the rest of the country well tell them
what's going on in Vermont because hey
in Vermont our state legislature
recently passed a medicare-for-all
single-payer piece of legislation the
governor is strongly supportive and we
think they said it the state Senate will
do the same so it is likely that the
state of Vermont may be the first state
in America to pass a cost-effective
healthcare system that guarantees health
care to all people to answer your
question if Vermont does it and if it
works well as I think it might my view
is that other states will follow it and
eventually we will have a national
Medicare for All single-payer program
which is what we should have
[Applause]
oh yeah alan arkin the voice that's what
do you think about that III certainly
yeah whatever the state of Vermont wants
to do is is their business and they'll
go through the legislative process
I certainly hope that doesn't happen
nationally I look at what goes on in
Europe for instance my sister-in-law
lives in London what goes on in Europe
people are healthy they have to go to a
doctor they just go to a doctor my
sister-in-law went to a doctor to give
birth and was told because she was too
fit too well in shape that she couldn't
have an epidural and and I think a lot
of Americans worry that we'll get to a
point where grin and bear it or hear
bite on this is gonna be our health care
that's very scary live longer than asked
they have a lower infant mortality rate
than us and they dress better than us
here's the reality
I mean anecdotes are not good enough I
mean the truth of the matter is that in
most of the European countries people
have healthcare as a right in our
country fifty million people have no
health insurance at all and we end up
spending twice as much as any other
country it doesn't make a lot of sense
so when people need emergency surgery
they can afford it they come to the
United States yeah if they're rich
people who have the money you're right
we have the best health care system in
the world but for the middle class and
working families that is not the case
45,000 Americans will die this year
because they don't have access to a
doctor right we could talk about
certainly we get you know can you talk
about portability or accessibility you
know with with rural health care as well
but you know I worry that if we think
health care is expensive now wait oh
it's free and and what's not true that
was not true but we know that it's not
true because every other country in the
world that has universal health care
spend significantly less per capita than
we do that's why
[Applause]
there's another part of the healthcare
debate that people don't listen to very
often which is the pre-existing
conditions issue when you work around
people with disabilities they have a lot
of pre-existing conditions and I was in
Nebraska several months ago when I was
talking to a guy who's a former cop he
said you know we're all so angry about
the healthcare obamacare it's a disaster
it's a disaster
and we were in a Special Olympics
environment 2,000 people with special
needs in Lincoln Nebraska and I said you
know I don't know that much about health
care I'm no expert but what I do know is
that the new law makes it impossible to
deny health care to people with
condition with pre-existing conditions
so for our athletes the new law is
really good news and the cop took a long
pause the former company said to me no I
never knew that was in the bill if I'd
known that was in the bill I would have
supported it and that's a provision
Republicans support it well I know but
I'm just saying a lot of Americans have
not unpacked the bill they haven't they
don't understand the pieces of health I
mean as you were saying
everybody wanted health care reform and
now all of a sudden everybody thinks
it's a bad idea because we've lost track
of what we really were after we really
were after allowing a person that adult
with Down syndrome to see a doctor and
not be denied by a health insurance
company or by some kind of health care
provider any access to care any access
to dental care I mean just on the face
of the fact that they have a disability
I mean those are the kinds of provisions
that inspire Americans to be great when
they remember you are fighting for
something good something you believe in
something that's just and all of a
sudden everything I thought what you do
[Applause]
here's what you got it wrong
bottom line the bottom line in this
debate every major country on Earth
guarantees healthcare as a right we
don't and we end up spending far more
than they do so I think what most
Americans want so is universal health
care in a cost-effective way
which happens to the Medicare for I
don't know if people know what there's a
group called our a.m. Remote Area
Medical are you familiar with them 60
minutes did a piece on them they used to
drop into third-world country and they
would you know it's a group of hundreds
of doctors who are volunteering their
tests dentists yes people they would
just go to a place you know godforsaken
[ __ ] holes of the world and people would
come from the village and the people who
you know just couldn't get dentistry
well now they work almost exclusively in
America they were here in Los Angeles a
major metropolitan city and people lined
up a full day in advance so they could
just get their teeth cleaned or have a
breast cancer exam now something has to
change in America when a third-world
organization has to drop in on this
country to them say we do the same thing
we have Dennis come to our events now
we have Dennis comes especially we do
about a hundred thousand health
screenings a year at these track needs
and the dentist come they volunteer and
we routinely find fifteen percent of the
athletes randomly screened go to the
emergency room go to the emergency room
from the track or from the swimming pool
because they have such acute dental or
oral cavity disease that they're at risk
of either acute pain which they're
suffering from and not identifying or
oral cancer when you in the United
States not in Rwanda where we also do
the same thing not in Afghanistan where
we also do the same thing but in New
Jersey California and the cost of course
it is so much greater when you let the
problems fester as opposed to that's
exactly right one of the issues that I
worked very hard on at health care
reform is doubling the number of
community health centers right study
after study shows just what you said if
you keep people from going to the
emergency right if you keep people from
getting very sick and ending up in the
hospital you save money all Boerne
studies are socialist
[Applause]